[Music]
my name is Marvin Arden I'm Khary Payton
I'm sorry I was taken aback by all these
[ __ ] like portals behind the bar I
don't know you guys can see this at home
but they put a fish lift on his mug look
at this so pre is pretty we could all
get away everybody take a pod yes
welcome to the for the time being anyway
the last the final black man be on
podcast I killed it you did you brought
it came in and I came in here kick this
thing's but it is the last one only
because Kevin is coming back on March
3rd which will be our next cabin moves
also I play when he's away and now that
he's not a way then the play goes away
you get there you still get to do your
thing
I started series a film series yes
that's right that's right a very
successful so far so far right the Alamo
Drafthouse downtown LA it's called the
Minority Report I'm all about a good
title absolutely but it's all about sort
of looking at genre films through a
diverse lens so it's like diverse
stories diverse filmmakers diverse
actors above and beyond through the
looking-glass all of that [ __ ] does
everybody have to shave their head I
mean I mean think about it
maybe all right cool just look at this
sexy drink they made for me well played
well played by yeah the first the first
film in the in the series is is serenity
oh nice yes we sold out 30 hours
downtown LA amen
I'm serenity i'ts you know brown coats
will unite they come and come hard
absolutely [ __ ] flair they will show
up
downtown LA which you know I'm not sure
I would go if I wasn't moderating this
it's it depends on what side of the
street you walk on it could sketch real
fast at downtown LA you know I do
believe that's where the Wayne's lost
their life was it downtown LA you could
literally be in the nicest theater in
the world and just take the wrong turn
and your mom and daddy are dead we will
speak the truth tonight
so says Rosa so say us all apparently we
both got the memo exactly exactly it's
Black History Month we never [ __ ]
around we're coming to the end so like
you show out exactly the funny thing is
I I don't think in in all my years I've
ever heard Rosa Parks say anything I've
only seen pictures so the idea that she
got on the bus and they were like they
were like you gotta get me she was like
nah just [ __ ] love that okay first of
all I have to make an announcement
ooh I love announcements yes me no it
doesn't I mean it does okay it does a
little bit it's just that you know that
I do cartoon voices and have done them
for there many years I've heard tell
exactly and so I just would like to make
a disclaimer if you haven't figured it
out already this is not a kid show I
will not be using my inside voice I will
not be using my kindergarten words so so
kids go to bed this is not for you
but up yet but I would like to tell them
a joke because because Eddie Murphy when
he did the same thing when he did
stand-up and he said go home this is not
buckwheat I'm gonna say some nasty [ __ ]
so so go but I'll tell you one joke and
this is the joke he told he said a bear
and a rabbit met in the woods and the
bear asked the rabbit do you have
trouble with [ __ ] sticking to your fur
and the rabbit said no I don't have
trouble with [ __ ] sticking to my fur so
the bear wiped his ass with the rabbit
now go to bed kids go to bed
alright I feel like I'm gonna get the
call on like the bat phone from Warner
Brothers being like oh you got to pull
them off
we need cyborgs to not be saying [ __ ]
like this in public in front of people
they're in all kinds of trouble if
that's the case so yeah whatever the
housekeeping is done yeah thank you for
[ __ ] joining me man you were like the
busiest man in the world yeah you know
what I'm just glad I could make it I I
love you guys I love this show I'm also
afraid of the show because whenever no
because well because I always watch
things late you know and so I want to
try it out but but then I know that
you're gonna spoil something for me
so I have to be so so I have to be
careful when I tune in but I love you
guys so much because because I love
Kevin's enthusiasm and I loved it that
he cries at everything and you're always
right so to me it's the perfect podcast
you know it's right it's always like
everything I was crying then and then it
stops for a minute and then you're like
and hear all the things that are bad
about this and he was like [ __ ] man
you're so smart whine and I think of
that
no we really don't
we just said like the black signal and
we're like hey can you come to the sky
mobility Cantina I gotta go did the
funny thing is is that is that we met
years ago at Long Beach I Long Beach
comic comic convention and I was I guess
I'm seeing a parent you were the main
speaker yeah it was for the the Dwayne
McDuffie for comic books yes award
exactly and and I I I just loved what he
had to say I didn't know who you were
before that and and and so I immediately
started following you on Twitter and
Instagram and
and so we had one of those weird you
know Instagram a man that was nice what
you just said but at least we can trace
it back to a thing exactly people I've
known for almost a decade that I don't
know where I met now or how I met they
just seemed to be a part of my life as I
go did we I don't know was there like a
drinks thing oh I could have been coming
to your house all this time we actually
met I mean you might have like one of my
TV's what's in your pantry yeah it was
it was a lovely event Dwayne McDuffie
who was one of the founding members of
the milestone universe at DC who created
static and who helped create icon rocket
yeah all that stuff was one of the best
comic book writers period to work in the
in the industry happen to be a big old
black dude and so happened to be all
about kind of helping to usher new
voices into the business absolutely and
champion the ones who were there and
telling stories at a time
stories about characters of color at a
time when nobody really wanted to do
that yeah in a fundamental way but he's
also dude who got to write The Avengers
and the Justice League and create his
own stuff and be in animation and wrote
a whole [ __ ] ton of like the just
ridiculously prolific absolutely no dude
yeah and like died too young way too you
know way too young in his late 40s I
believe or early 50s it was it I mean I
don't it was I think it wasn't in his
40s he was he seemed like a baby to me
you know when I yeah if he was in his
50s he looked good for 50 yeah yeah he
wrote the Justice League new frontier
animated movie and some of the last
pictures of him are at the premiere for
that movie and so when he passed away
like his his widow kind of took it upon
herself to carry that torch yeah and to
help establish this sort of award for
for people of color who were writing in
comic books and doing really great work
and just be able to shine a light on
that and so it was the second maybe yeah
I'm Dwayne McDuffie Awards and they
asked me to be the keynote speaker
because I ripped Dwayne McDuffie off
like 9 or 10 times and they were like
well clearly you now have to come
right that was I met him once and I told
him like I shamelessly ripped off damage
control oh we're TT and vendor for
Marvel if you've never a damage control
it's this amazing book about like what
happens when you know Galactus comes to
New York and destroy Central Park and
there's still a Central Park who
rebuilds it and damage control where the
people who like the insurance adjusters
and the the repair guys and triage and
they would come in and like rebuild the
New York that gets destroyed every
[ __ ] issue of every [ __ ] comic
book right and so I shamelessly ripped
that off for this book called master
attack network which is said on this
like Pacific island where Godzilla's and
Mothra's and giedrius are like nasty and
would destroy [ __ ] Hawaii every issue
and these were the guys who fixed it and
when I met him in comic-con I was like
hey dude listen i-i've been ripping you
off on this book for like a year it's a
no Maj there's your ripoff he's like we
all do it I did it people before me did
it you do it it's how we get this done
right like we see something we like you
make it your own and I was always super
humbled by the fact that he was that
magnanimous about his own genius and so
when they asked me to do it I was super
[ __ ] honored to and you were the
emcee the event yeah yeah hey this guy's
cool hey funny and now like five years
later we are here we [ __ ] are for the
people at home who are not intimately
familiar with you in your career walk us
through a little bit I mean the the big
ones that people might know okay well
I'm
I've been cyborg from teen titans for 17
years now the voice of cyborg I guess
that the original original essay but I
but I you know cyborg was around a lot
lat before the cartoon from the early
2000s but I yeah yeah so I was I've been
cyborg and now and I've done cyborg in a
lot of different iterations mostly now I
do AI do kind of a very irreverent
silly version of a cyborg on a show
called Teen Titans go that's thank you
very much thank you very much for not
listening to the internet and
and everybody who's mad that is not the
old show but it's it's really brilliant
actually and and I I think it's success
comes from the fact that that a kid
started watching it and we stopped
writing for the kids about 20 episodes
in and it just started writing for the
parents you know it was like I've been
there shows about you know how not to
get involved in pyramid schemes how to
buy a mortgage you know you know it's
it's you know how the university system
is broken
exactly for the children it's so I so
that's been great and I I and recently I
guess semi recently about about just
just a few months after we met actually
I started working on on The Walking Dead
I play play King as we killed on The
Walking Dead thank you very much Oh
y'all it is still watching that's so
nice it's like I mean there's still a
lot of people that watch they were just
there was just 8 million people that
stopped watching right before I started
on the show you know it was like
literally the episode before me they
were like okay [ __ ] you that's too much
and I was like no no but aggressive
Colin campaigns like hey guys we should
like stop watching juice before he gets
just booked I'm telling you it was it
was weird it was like it was like I mean
I just recently went vegan so my farts
don't stink as much as they used to but
but it was like I just rip one and they
just left the room I don't know dude I I
occasionally work with a vegan and
they're worse Arlie you know I try to
keep moving so I just leave the cloud
behind me duck and weave baby true is
true sprouts will do you
and we'll put that on a t-shirt that's
gonna be my next one so sprouts will do
you do it
but yeah yes although those are the main
things I I also have been on I don't
know if it's a cult favorite because
it's actually a pretty successful
cartoon called Young Justice where I
play several characters including I
called the ROM who who was Aqualad who's
now Aquaman and and Black Lightning and
Black Manta if there's a black in the
name I'm probably playing it and wait
for your black working oh you know I'm
gonna have a couple more drinks and you
can see the black market it's amazing I
didn't want to see it
I just wanted to hear it you just wanted
to hear it run real fair for you to yeah
let's just stop with that so uh anyway
your justice I do your justice and what
else doing oh I I spent time role
playing in my off time a lot of times
doing a Dungeons & Dragons online as
what is your what is your character
class of choice my character class of
choice is AI is a tempest cleric by the
name of Shikata he's a he's actually a
blind eye
tempest cleric or whether storm cleric
who are sees through the eyes of a
hummingbird who's whose name is uh is
the the grand duchess anastasia
nicolaevna grand duchess sits on on his
shoulder right there yeah he has a
beautiful white afro that one day I'll
be able to I'll be able to grow back if
when they finally kill me office clerk
was from Chicago that would be yeah yeah
so it so he just talks kind of like a
you know you got more sausage back where
the hell is the sausage exactly so yeah
he eats all the sausage because I'm
I'm a vegan now so that's a natural 20
[ __ ] critical hit yeah it is it is
and we also did this on this cool thing
where we did Deadwood we did we did a
like a role-playing game of the show
Deadwood but it's but it was kind of
mystical and supernatural and it was
called undead wood it was kind of like
you take my two you take zombies and in
role-playing and and in Deadwood and put
them all together and we did like a
four-part miniseries of that and that
was so much fun
who is this we you speak oh there's we
is it's all of my critical role people
from let's see Matt Matt Mercer Maria
Rey all of those jokers Travis Travis
big big-ass travis willingham big-ass
right exactly uh Brian Foster was I the
the the DM DM murmur fellow so yeah
exactly see I know all of the other
technical terms the thing is I only
played Dungeons and Dragons with my
daughter's twice you know before I
actually started doing this I'm good at
make-believe I don't know any of the
rules and I don't remember any of the
term just be glad I remember my
character's name yeah and your
daughter's names you know that's you're
a busy [ __ ] man I try to be busy I
buy I recently got my first writing job
oh my god I'm so excited
welcome yeah of course I can't say
anything about it other than I am doing
it and that I'm incredibly excited for
it I'm I found out that I am just the
kind of wedge nerd that is perfectly
suited for this particular job you know
cuz because I've written things before
and I've produced things before on my
own but but never in a in a writers room
sort of situation and you know and I
wasn't sure how
how I was gonna navigate it and no it
turned out I was like oh man I got this
all of my nerd DNA I can flow right into
this [ __ ] it's gonna be amazing so and
if it doesn't work they think I have a
tiger yeah I think I had a tag no you
are so busy I was surprised that today
we were we were you know DMM back and
forth about you know shows gonna know
whatever you like yeah I'm gonna go see
birds of prey at noon say how do you
have time to go see birds of prey at
noon you're busy dude and but no no no I
mean this is my this is my off time so
so I you know from the show so I'm a
little bit freer as far as my time was
concerned I I do I am a busy ski
instructor these days wait what yeah
yeah if I wasn't doing bird-of-prey then
I was probably gonna be a big bear
teaching like 13 year olds how to ski
I'm sorry
yeah no it's crazy I'm trying to square
all these circles in my head oh I always
try to broaden your horizons man you
know it was like it's you try what I
like to do is is it'd be like a black
man from Georgia who didn't see snow
until he was like 17 and now I now I ski
on a regular basis I love this [ __ ] I
love Southern California ya know I'm all
for broaden your horizons but just on
things with brakes and steering wheels
like you're just hurtling yourself into
the void just like praying like I hope
these skis stick I've been hurtling
myself into the void for years you know
I'm just using different apparatus at
this point you know I started off like
breakdancing like when my performing you
know bug kind of started I started off
breakdancing and and and I was tiny when
I was when I was little I mean by the
time I got into high school I wasn't
quite 5 feet tall I wasn't quite a
hundred pounds I could throw my body all
kinds of weird weird ways and and they'd
be like you know tow it his mouth that's
crazy
he's spinning on his finger with his toe
and so you know in my tiny little town
of Athens Georgia you know I was I was I
was the man boy I've been I think I've
just been looking for crazy ways to you
know to maim myself and the nice thing
is I had to stop playing basketball
because because my right knee wouldn't
let me anymore and because I play
basketball even though I'm I'm pushing
I'm pushing mid-century you know I still
play like I'm 25 but that's a problem I
just learned to ski so I like better 46
it's you know so that's okay I had to
stop playing basketball because my knee
hurts so instead I took a bungee jumping
what the [ __ ] is that as long as you
don't hit the ground you gonna be frying
your elbows to throttle backwards man
you go get close to the ground just
close to the ground and you'll be fine
it's like I picked up macrame better for
you that's body injuries no I picked up
cannon firing myself at distance but I
don't eat meat no more so Italy
that's your trailer so when I slam into
something at least I'll be healthy when
I die you know I took a William telling
I just let people shoot hours and apples
in my head all right it's safe it's
track you know I got I gotta stay in
shape somehow man I can't play
basketball so I got to do something
because I still got to swing a sword and
kill zombies you know when I when they
asked me back to work today I was I was
just uh hiking up to the wisdom tree up
here you know the wisdom tree I've heard
of it it's beautiful I've never seen it
yeah you probably won't know it's it's
not it's not an easy trip but I but I
used to take my youngest daughter on my
put her in a little backpack and take
her up with me and now she got too big
and at the back of her legs would you
know start kicking me in the thigh and
you know she just didn't fit the
backpack anymore because when they do
that that's called kidnapping yeah there
you go it's so I got a weight pack and
it started taking a weight pack up and
in the thing about the weight pack is
when you do it the first time you're
trying to be careful you don't want to
hurt yourself you like let's do it and
say and you get all the way up there and
you're like
look at you you made it all the way up
through which we pack on so the next
time you get up there and you're like
I'm up this thing and I get about I
don't know 1/3 2/3 of the way way up and
I start breathing so hard you start
seeing through time you start you know
what I mean like like like the Friends
of you know your ancestors come up and
and all talking like deep Johnny Cash
voices to you you know and then and all
the ladies who you were impressing on
the way up or like it's okay you're
almost there you know all the jedis who
would died before show off me make it
you can no no no it's just Yoda laughing
backwards yes exactly exactly expensive
ways to hurt yourself
you know live it until they take it away
that's what I say keep keep it up until
they take it away when when do you go
back for four more zombie-killing well
if I survive this next season which
starts back on February 23rd very
excited absolutely so I so I have to
survive eight more episodes okay the I
that's why I don't I I don't work when
people are worried about you know if
their show is gonna get can it's like
every week every week I'm like you know
at least you know you know what the show
may get cancelled after your 22-episode
run every every day I get a script and
I'm like hi thanks survive the next
eight episodes then I we usually go back
in May so and like you know making sure
that they do delivering scripts like
stops by your trailers equator I don't
get a script this week well I literally
put on like a hood and carry a sickle
[Music]
it's dark it's dark and I like to read
this group this week
so yes you did take some time today to
go see birds of prey I did I did I've
now seen it twice I saw that you went to
see it twice that itself seems like a
bit of a commentary no you saw that
twice no no I made money and everything
both times no no no I bet there were I
enjoyed a lot of the movie I enjoyed a
lot of the movie I I I liked it better
the second time I saw it because I find
that a lot in that once I'm absolved
from expecting anything from a movie I'm
allowed to appreciate actually what it
is sure sure not that I expected very
much going into records of prey I
expected better than Suicide Squad which
I got sure I was quite happy about that
there's parts of the movie that I liked
quite a bit yeah I think Margot Robbie
is doing really really interesting work
as Harley I'm gonna be an interesting is
like a like oh no that child is
breathtaking no I mean interesting like
actually interesting work right right
and she's found the the core of what
makes that character tick and there's a
couple of scenes throughout that are
just fantastic little baby it's kind of
like diagrams as to what makes that
character work there are moments where
she really sinks down into not the
caricature of what we think of as Harley
but but but a flawed and quaint in those
quiet moments there's everybody seen
birds of prey yeah cuz cuz we may spoil
some [ __ ] yeah yeah no I'm just saying
swirling may happen I mean if you
haven't then then [ __ ] you I don't know
why you're here
I mean he literally tweeted about this
[ __ ] like twice you know so this isn't
our fault this is your fault but there's
a meal the whole goddamn movie all got
in a movie but there's this amazing
scene about a third of the way through
where Harley Quinn is at the bar at
Roman Co nurse's place and she's drunk
off her ass and
Dinah Lance comes over next to her and
like it's the first time those two
characters mean even though it's clear
they've seen each other before and and
Harley you know I was like you know I do
you know what a Harlequin is like you
know in literature do you know what that
character's job is like she's she's a
clown she's there to serve a master
without that master she has no purpose
in life yes you know and she's a help
she's a helper she's supposed to support
something else she she's like you know
she's peanut butter without jelly she's
and without that unity that character
traditionally has notes no idea what to
do with herself right and she confesses
for the first time that she broke up
with the Joker and like and she doesn't
know what to do with herself and I'm
like that's fascinating yeah like given
what we know about this character how
she had for her entire existence been
yeah no come on in come on in he was
just about to tear up with the [ __ ] he
was gonna say but thank you for bringing
that up
oh you let them be fake showed up they
came to play all wrong but yeah and like
that that scene is I'm not gonna leave
you alone okay rest of the night I'm
[ __ ] with you go ahead I'm sorry go
ahead
he look now it was me now it was me oh
you did you need a tissue I'm gonna get
you here you know I got a long shirt no
there's a box of kid tissues under here
but that's what the movies about it's
about a woman who had been for so long
defined by the man she was with deciding
not to be with that guy anymore and then
who is she in the absence to that person
and every now and again in the movie
glance glances against that idea but not
quite enough for me yeah you know it's
sort of forgot about that at that moment
and and honestly it's kind of
interesting because that's the name of
the movie you know it's it's the
fantabulous emancipation of one harley
quinn and and that's that really is what
this movie is because it's not birds of
prey it's it's it's it's a story of
Harley Quinn and I and if if if we're
doing it right I mean you can read into
all of that stuff but it I don't think
it it it told that story
quite proficiently enough that this was
literally Harlequin going from a support
and someone who needed a master to
someone who who can stand on her own
yeah and like and the movie kind of
missed its opportunities to reinforce
that story right like I thought you know
Gregor is playing every shitty Hollywood
executive I've ever had a meeting with
yeah yeah like he's just thoroughly
egocentric and like dazzled by the Daffy
[ __ ] like here are masks I got an bog
way and he's having a blast playing this
sort of thoroughly entitled thoroughly
privileged dude who doesn't see that
privilege but still thinks he's owed a
bunch of [ __ ] right kind of delicious
but I kept on wanting he hates Harley
Quinn for reasons that are fundamentally
cerfancy right which is like you know
you were always impenetrable because you
were the Joker's girl but now you're not
I want to kill you why because you beat
up one of my guys once and you make fun
of my name right because he can honestly
it was because you know what you were
something I couldn't [ __ ] with and now I
can and and I hated you because you were
something that I couldn't [ __ ] with and
I could usually [ __ ] with everything
right you know the thing that I kind of
wanted was for him to have been in love
with Harley oh and like if here's a guy
who always had an eye for Harley but
knew that he couldn't even make a play
cuz she was the Joker's girl and now
she's not the Joker's girl and he makes
a play and she turns him down because
she as establish and said I want to be
my own person for the first time in my
life Oh myself making the movie better I
thought it was good and you're [ __ ]
making it better
[ __ ] that [ __ ] was [ __ ] amazing
you're [ __ ] awesome man I swear to
God I didn't even think of it I'm a
[ __ ] [ __ ] but like if that's if
her if her turning him down is the
reason why he then wants to kill her
because we've established he gets
whatever he wants yeah
and he now we can't have it then that
informs his story and why he does the
business it informs her story it helps
to under sort of reinforce her story and
reinforce her desire to sort of build
this girl gang to help her figure out
right who's she supposed to be in the
absence of some
domineering male domineering milf it
right right yeah and that that's the
thing I guess that that it that it never
really took on it they're they're all of
these it is definitely women kicking
some ass and I in and that's amazing but
uh but but the the deeper dive into it I
think is is where maybe it missed the
point and and I and and also there
there's this thing that they would do in
the movie where where where they would
start the action the action would kind
of you know crescendo and get really
good and then they'd stop and go back
and tell us tell a story like you don't
know how we got here let me explain to
you how I don't give a [ __ ] I was like
just keep kicking them in the balls just
kick him in the balls tomorrow was so
good and I mean I get that we that in a
way we needed that backstory I would
have liked to have maybe told the told
the story in a more linear sense cuz
when they went back they really went
back to tell everything and and I would
have loved to ever heard those stories
and the voices of the women that were
going through it you know but like the
only reason sort of dramatically to do
that yeah y'all better get the [ __ ] on I
swear the guy I swear the guy y'all
gonna come through here I'll not clean
white t-shirts I'm gonna [ __ ] that
t-shirt what is on that t-shirt now you
know I don't know we're not better have
a conversation I'm just joking gonna
keep on walking out the door
they keep oh you're almost there and
they go okay alright I'm sorry I am so
bad at hosting a show by the time went
into this theory there's ghosts gonna be
me you and somebody sweeping the floor
that is it that is it and then you'll
turn on me and then I'll be like why the
[ __ ] did you bring me here you wore that
shirt you knew I was gonna wear that
shirt while encouraged by must on me by
my [ __ ] stuff why is your knob bigger
than mine ah
genetics I guess genetics genetics but
yeah I mean I just think there's there's
I'm having such a good time I I'm so
glad you know what one person in here is
having a very good time and it's me it's
me
as you prophesied mother you like hey
listen if nobody shows up which is you
and me I'm gonna have a blast have a
good time you know I have never been to
the cantina of scum and villainy and I'm
very busy I keep hearing the body you
know it was popping up a while popping
up for a while and I was like I keep
missing I keep missing it and then it
was just here and then I was just not
here oh you know Atlantis lands on me
exactly and so this was or you know
somewhere teaching thirteen years how to
ski and and now yeah I'm just so happy
to be in your old white children on a
mountain that seems like there are some
Asian children as well
good okay mostly white some Asian and
every once in a while there's a 17 year
old black kid who got lost
[Laughter]
how did I end up at the top of his
Mountain only way down son exactly so
yes I think that that the the sort of
fractured storytelling doesn't actually
add anything to it it feels as if it was
used to put action scenes where they
felt that it was lagging a bit yeah
there's like oh she's gotta kick some
ass here we don't know why so let's just
[ __ ] we'll figure it out later
yeah and that but now that being said I
thought that the fight choreography was
phenomenal and once it started I was
loving it
I was absolutely loving it and I was
wishing I was in there getting my legs
you know broken in the wrong way you
know just just knees popped in horrible
directions it felt like inconsistent at
times where like sometimes she's a
[ __ ] baseball bat ninja and then
sometimes she kind of get
a skate for reasons that don't seem
legit you know what but I understand
that being being an individual with ADHD
you forget you know how to fight yeah
absolutely you forget you know how to
fight
you know hold on you are not neo when
you are ADHD you are not neo you know
just don't know kung fu
you know kung fu sometimes and that's
that that's how we're and and the thing
is it's like it's like when she it's
it's like when they started shooting the
cocaine and she sucked it up and she was
like I know kung fu you know it's like
sometimes you need that aspect of you
know something to trigger you into
reminding you of who you are and and so
that I kind of understood because there
were definitely times where she was just
flighty and kind of like Oh stuffs
flying around me you know I got hit in
the face I don't know I don't know what
to do that that reminded me of the of
the times where I'm standing in a room
where there's just piles of [ __ ]
everywhere and somebody walks in and
they were like what have you been
knowing for the last three hours and I
was like staring and all of this and
then I I've been sitting in this room do
you not see the piles of [ __ ] all around
my feet exactly you know but they
rocking but then I can ski down the
mountain and you know what I can you
know I can I can talk a blue streak so
there are we brought you here exactly
exactly some way you got to feel these
two hours but then but I love that there
are moments in that movie that feel like
I love movies that that come at it from
a completely different perspective than
I was expecting it to but there's a
version of this movie that's directed by
[ __ ] Michael Bay which is awful
that's true it's like the worst that's
true you know and there are times when
he gets close when there's like there's
all this smoke and the smoke is like
pink and purple and there's [ __ ]
confetti everywhere you're like oh no
this could be a Transformers movie that
I hadn't seen before
no but there's a but you know what there
is a little something underneath all of
that confetti you know there's it like
there's this is one great it's a moment
blinkin you're missing is the big final
[ __ ] fight scene in the booby hatch
movie trap and and canary is fighting in
or [ __ ] dreadlocks are getting in her
eyes and I love that Harley swings
always like hair tie and she's just like
I don't know where just gives her a hair
tie and that's part of the [ __ ] scene
absolutely looking out for each other
it's huge
excuse a hair time and as a dad with
daughters is like you know what I mean
cuz I got hair ties everywhere you know
especially because I got a daughter
who's a tomboy you know who like loves
for me to comb her her beautiful
gorgeous locks but if she ever gets near
the door she's like Daddy you need to
tight his back you know so to keep this
[ __ ] out of my face so I can do what I
do and and and when she did that it was
it was a little bit of dad in me that
was like yeah I got one right here
you know I got scrunchies up there was
oh my god I love that that that is that
that is a beautiful moment it really is
it's like just tiny and so well observed
I wish there were more of those moments
and that they happened earlier there's a
moment with with between Cassandra Cain
and and and hunters we're we're for
obvious reasons hunters was like come
over here you don't need to see this
right
I saw [ __ ] when I was your age you don't
need to see all of this actually this is
more fun yeah you should watch this but
but but there were there were those
little moments that I that I really
would it's one of those reasons that I
was like I wish they had told their
story because the story from their
perspective is is one that we haven't
heard before you know like I kept on
feeling that I either wanted there to be
more of the quote-unquote birds of prey
or less because and you want more
because you wanted to feel like it's a
girl gang movie right leg you want to
feel it's Harley's finding her people
for the first time in her life she's
discovered these three women from these
various walks of life who come into hers
and are making her better for it yeah
you kind of want that to be early in the
movie then it happens it becomes like
functional yeah we're not gonna get out
of here alive unless we all team up you
want it to be I am responding to what
you are and how you are and how unique
and lovely you are be part of my circle
because the circle is better for it yeah
or like not at all and just have it be
[ __ ] Harley Quinn learning to stand
on her own and learning to face down
this [ __ ] like idiot dude who won't
take her signals that she's not
interested who's trying to like I'm
gonna deliver this kid and like maybe be
a bad mom but maybe be a great mom but
figure out my [ __ ] as I go right you
know without having to take the time and
tell like kind of fractionally these
other stories it's so hard when you're
when you're building a team doing that
sting you know doing that Ocean's eleven
the the time that you have to is so
short that you have to have all of these
characters being daring you know in one
way or another and the thing is is that
all of them work you you you you do feel
for all of them in a certain sense but
but uh but maybe never together in in in
in in a way that they're like they're
like pulls them all the way to you know
what I mean into that team sense you
know there's there's the whole like
Black Canary run is interesting where
it's like listen my mother was a [ __ ]
superhero and I hated it and I hated the
cops because they burned my mom and so I
got no time for you Renee Montoya I got
no time for this whole thing right I'm
gonna be dragged into this story kicking
and screaming but we don't get a sense
really of how she feels about her mom
right you know like so what is that
what's the character story that we tell
about her perspective on her mother in
perspective in heroes and a perspective
on her own power
yeah which she seems to not want to use
sure for reasons that are never actually
put out there so that if you tell that
story when she's forced to be her mother
at the end and when she's forced to let
that [ __ ] canary cry fly yeah then
it's like oh [ __ ] she's finally come to
grips with what it meant to be a hero
right with what her mother gave up with
what like the sacrifices all of it means
something in this moment as it is it's
just [ __ ] cool but it's like oh it
could actually be character it could
actually be
oh you've you've crossed your own
personal like Rubicon er you figured out
some [ __ ] for yourself and that's so
hard it's so hard to do
be able to put all of these things in in
place going back and forth in time and
and I can see things getting lost you
know and and and I feel like I feel it
because at the beginning as this as the
movie was starting I was I I was like I
don't know if this guy got anything that
that's that's gonna capture me and by
the by the end I was I was swept up I
was I was loving and appreciating you
know a lot of those a lot of these
aspects it just it was it was just maybe
that the chapters just weren't is tight
you know as I as you may have wanted
them to be both times I saw it but there
are moments that I felt like they could
have turned the volume up on so sure
sure and this is a movie that felt like
it was built for the volume to be turned
absolutely and like just more pat
benatar
[ __ ] give me more hearts more Barret
absolutely like and if you turn some of
the volume up on those things that make
those characters tick right everything
else kind of resonates more yeah you
know everything else just has more heart
and more bounce and like oh [ __ ] you
want to tell the story out of continuity
I get it because I'm understanding the
character's story all the way through
right right um I I dug it again like
more the second time than the first time
but I honestly did dig it I was dismayed
to see the the box-office for it yeah
it's not bad it's not bad like it's it
made 33 million dollars in the
box-office domestically its opening
weekend um all in at this point is made
some 148 million across the world right
right um Batman Begins only made like 42
million dollars its opening weekend
difference is not huge sure sure what it
is always telling but it's the time but
but between the time and ticket prices
at this time it you know the the thing
is is that you're hoping that maybe that
the thing about action movies is is that
they definitely have a life after after
you know the the initial you know box
office returns go in like say something
like the Bourne Identity made a billion
dollars after it was you know released
but and so there there's a
chance of that happening the thing is is
that the that that just the world is so
saturated with action stuff but but yeah
yeah the the worry is that you might not
get the next one if it doesn't have legs
you know I mean and the narrative that
gets told about failures versus
successes depending on who is in the
failure or the success you know like the
interpretation of this performance is
going to be sadly because Hollywood is
Hollywood
there isn't an audience for this kind of
content so we're not going to make this
kind of content as opposed to we did a
shitty job of selling this content right
like birds have praised the wrong title
for this movie why is this a bird of
prey it's not it should have just been
like the fantabulous emancipation of
Harley Quinn that is the movie that that
is the movie that we saw yeah exactly
characters everybody recognizes but
doesn't know birds of prey from from a
[ __ ] hole in the wall exactly or you
know or don't do it for people like me
who like where's Barbara Gordon you're
gonna do a whole person a movie excuse
me without Barbara Gordon I mean I am
NOT the biggest comic book nerd but if
there's not a woman in a wheelchair in a
nest somewhere keeping everything
together then I don't know what does
where where's this birds of prey you
know there's got to be a nest yeah and
there's got to be Oracle in the nest
that's who keeps the [ __ ] together she's
talking to everyone they got a little
[ __ ] earpiece in the air they talk to
her all the [ __ ] time yes
[Applause]
amen I don't mean to cast aspersions on
some of the corporate benefactors
exactly oh [ __ ]
I hope this this Walking Dead thing
lasts a while because I'm never gonna
work again yeah I do to deliver scripts
and Warner Brothers is passing by your
trailer yeah
you don't like me anyway don't like you
anyway all right should we get into some
[ __ ] news yeah let's talk the news
man let's get into the news all the news
that is fit to print this is a this is
the part of the show as kept likes to
say when I go to the internet and copy
paste some [ __ ] and then read it out
loud
somebody's got to do it somebody's got
it's hard work man
you know what like you typed that no
that's copy paste man I'm just telling
you like that Oh control-c control-v
like return return return I literally
when you sent it to me and I was like
wow he typed all this [ __ ] out for me
this is yes yes I did I worked so hard
on this today it took me like 45 minutes
Wow yeah all right
so suddenly we read your [ __ ] page I
wasn't you know what I played a little
sonic but I I never got like crazy into
it you know I was confused I've seen
hedgehogs you know you got another [ __ ]
it doesn't look like a hedgehog I was
just having a conniption
every time I will put it on in and it
was you know and I would you I'd never
got enough coins that's the story
yeah that's the story that's a story
yeah I'm familiar with two kinds of
Hedgehog the Hedgehog that lives in
people's [ __ ] gardens and ron jeremy
neither of which is in this movie wait
is is Ron Jeremy's nickname Hedgehog
yeah sometimes Idol just I just don't
need to know [ __ ]
all right well sorry yeah that's all
right
but if you've ever seen that dude it no
don't that it does check out goddamn it
they were all so cute okay like I'm sure
right now there's a bunch of like dudes
to make sort of girlfriend that dudes
like I know when the girls like what all
right yeah okay you know what let's yeah
let's let's talk more Hedgehog so sonic
the first trailers for Sonic the
Hedgehog here and they looked like like
[ __ ] warmed over
they look like ron jeremy blue he was
like i'm so hairy oh you can see all the
individual hands i know i'm gray blue
dude you know what it's my fault I'm
sorry this makes sense now it all does
we've come full circle so yeah the first
trailer looked awful because they
animated Sonic like he I don't know what
you know it they were trying to make him
into Howard to dunk from way back you
know yes which worked out so well
exactly
and so fan outrage there was a huge
human cry and and so paramount went back
and redesigned the CG models for solid
and yes they did at great expense when
you spared no expense the movie came out
this past weekend Valentine's Day right
perfect Valentine's Day viewing and made
70 million dollars in its opening
weekend boom which you know birds of
prey 33 South edgehog 70 okay whatever
you know what but sonic may made a lot
more money sonic also cost a lot more
money I don't know that it did you know
I'm just gonna assume because they had
to go and reacquaint sonic with his body
and they also had to pay Jim Carrey to
put that mustache on
because as a man who has to put on hair
for a living you gonna have to pay me to
keep doing that
because although I am grateful and I
appreciate it that [ __ ] is itchy after
17 hours so what I heard through my
dropout son he just beamed right down
through the Barnard bar gossip trickled
down in Hollywood oh really is that the
hive of scum yes the marketing company
behind Sonic was asked how do we make
Sonic relevant and they said play into
nerd rage they animated Sonic to look
like [ __ ] for the trailer only and that
they actually released it and then nerds
rage on the internet and they said we'll
fix it we'll spend the money to fix it
so that people felt like they made a
difference and they'd go out and see
Sonic that is some [ __ ] if I've
never heard it that that that is some
boss trying to pretend that he was in
control of [ __ ] the whole time that is
some [ __ ] mr. and mrs. Sonic you lie
or that is some like [ __ ]
three-dimensional next level like
[ __ ] Stephen Miller
evil chess it yes yes it could be that
but more than likely that is that
somebody in a PR room some that was like
don't worry about this we're gonna say
this it's gonna be fine I'm saying man
like if that isn't it what happened it's
gonna be what happens next yeah yeah
yeah and it realizes like artists and
low-hanging fruit knows we can make them
angry we can be there's a there's a term
that gets used in writers rooms a lot
called arsonist fireman mm-hmm or it's
you cause problems only to then be the
hero who swoops in to solve the problems
like I set this fire and then okay I got
a fire van outside
this fire I'm your [ __ ] hero like
this is some of that [ __ ] was like I
caused a problem for me to fix to look
like a hero and then to engender myself
to legions of people who would never see
this ordinarily because now they feel
some sense of ownership are gonna show
out to prove that fans should have that
final say man you know how many jobs you
just saved for me this is amazing you
know I'm not writing this down because
this is being recorded but I'm
definitely don't remember that [ __ ]
everybody write that down that's good
yeah so Sonic beta [ __ ] ton of money I'm
I'm afraid that there's going to be if
that version of it is true that there
will be a point like it's the the bcad
switch right like Jesus is the zone for
there was an old world and now there's a
new world well you know what it's funny
because you remember when Captain
America First Avenger came out and they
they brought out like the goofy you know
you know what do you call it um not VFW
but USO version of you know and
everybody like lost it and was like all
pissed off and they and I remember them
think that there was something in maybe
Entertainment Weekly I think with it
where the producers were like oh we got
them they think that that's it you know
and I was like I was like oh man you did
get me you totally got me
I was like doing this [ __ ] for years
sons of [ __ ] sons of [ __ ] I love
that movie I've been manipulated once
again
it felt so good it did you did I love a
good manipulation man it's the truth I
don't mind getting manipulated if if you
manipulate me with like goodwill and
intent glad you say goodwill and intent
because this this conversation was about
to get weird
but I'm sorry is it weird or is it
special it's special it's that welcome
to the special Spielberg is like the
king of manipulation like he is just
doing nothing but playing us like
[ __ ] fiddle fiddle and I welcome it
every damn time yes even when I see it
coming like what is this girl with the
red dress and shivers list oh you want
me to cry now uh-huh
here you go Stephen you worked for it
playing E to pay off in the middle of
dare you that's out there you find a
record player in the middle of this
death and destruction killed my you just
want my tears I'm gonna be your vampire
you suck the joy out of my tears I see
it see you how dare you you just got him
bottled up in your house like some kind
of crazy gray garden style hoarder just
walls and walls and mark tears y'all
just drew barrymore talking to a robot
thinking it's real man I need a minute
did you see a Matt Reeves who's
directing the new the Batman picture
dropped a little like 30 second chum of
[ __ ] little part in each Acula into
the into the universe absolutely
it was a tiny little look it's just like
mm-hmm
you know what it's like back in the day
when when Michael Jackson would jump
onstage and be like still for 20 minutes
and then just turn everybody go also
like yeah like like in smooth criminal
yeah like you could flip a coin from
across the room and it land right in in
the slot he's somehow
managed to convince a lot of people do a
lot of things some of which not very
good at all but the world thought he was
a badass like for like eight minutes
like he's got the bandoliers on and each
of them has metals like gold he's like
the shiniest [ __ ] Bandolero dude yeah
yeah yeah [ __ ] soldier telling you he
was marching leaning so much like he was
it was literally like he's like would
you like to read that he's like will
they bring it closer he was like no need
meanwhile the sisters over there like
[ __ ] marching rhythm nation like
looking like nine times tougher than he
ever did sure like in the show I got
this glove right [ __ ] like armband
[ __ ] like you know what he was doing
plus two against Wars saying and Matt
Reeves took all that information way to
bring him back
eyes are trying to find a way to circle
back to Batman but you did that but yeah
so it's it's [ __ ] what's-his-face
Sparkle vampire dude Pattinson right in
a bat suit and it's all read for reasons
that I don't quite understand cuz sure
but there was developing photos yeah
he's in his dark room exactly dark room
songs if you'd pan down lower you'd see
the tongs and he just flip the play
paper over just the whole [ __ ] row in
the back just pictures hung on it
it's just Commissioner Gordon like in
the shower in his backyard sunning
himself like at the beach this this this
show writes itself it's easy it really
does it's just called like according to
Jim Batman just fascination go according
to Jim Gordon and you go Saturday nights
at 8:00 my favorite part of the Harley
Quinn animated show yeah which I now
love to death is that and and if you
haven't seen it it's [ __ ] amazing
just bit in the first episode where you
meet Commissioner going to Batman for
the first time and Gordon is like
literally this [ __ ] dude is like
barely holding on to his coffee mug
which clearly filled with scotch
like Batman swoops in and halogens
he [ __ ] bats I [ __ ] it I got [ __ ]
bats done Nate and Jim's like yeah I
don't [ __ ] bad so I do want lucky the
drunk kind of you know way on edge ADHD
Jim Gordon who's been scared on the top
of that roof so many times
nervous condition goddammit and another
conversation on the roof son of a [ __ ]
could you not surprise me just knock
that be fine right
so yeah they met a Batman suit yeah what
did you what did you think of said that
my said I mean of what I could see about
it it could be cool you know I mean we
didn't even see the top of the cowl we
didn't even see the ears really we you
know so so it was it was it was it was a
tiny little bit I thought I think he's
got a great job he's got good job for
that he's got the job for the role you
know I think that I think that he's been
spending his his time doing really
interesting you know cool and and
unburied work you know and so I and and
I'm I'm kind of excited to see what
comes next I think I think we're we're
all you know pretty in love with this
this this one bit of you know I guess
reveal that I do you want to talk about
that yeah it's it's the the prevailing
theory is that the bat-signal that
symbol on his chest looks like it's made
of kind of like wrought metal and some
like it's it doesn't look like the
regular old [ __ ] like the black and
yellow ever seen before that make black
one or what have you it looks like it's
made from another thing and so the
prevailing theory is that it's the the
gun that Joe Chill used to shoot his
parents he's recovered and welded into
the bat symbol itself that he now wears
on his chest which I love to death and I
love it for so many reasons but the
chief of which is Kevin invented that
idea that's not like Kevin
Kevin Smith you know the guy who's
usually there yeah imagine me whiter
yeah not that much heavier that same
vegan no you know it's all practically
the same yeah but a hockey shirt on me
and I'm it's me a nice pink blazer
absolutely buttons but he and Gimli had
done a story for the Batman 1000 issue
that that that was the the idea
ultimately behind it is that that he it
was always an armor to chest plate yeah
it had been since Frank Miller did it in
in Dark Knight Returns and and Kev's
innovation was his master stroke was
that that armor is made from the melted
down revolver that killed his parents
mmm and so he's keeping that so close to
the chest literally
because it's protecting him from the
world and it's reminding him of why he
does it
I I'm just wondering how many times like
Kevin had to write that over because his
tears just made the ink run you know as
he was writing you just know there's a
stack of short circuited out laptop all
over the I mean cuz that came from the
heart right there oh yeah absolutely
so even if that's not what that is I'm
going to believe that that we're all
gonna believe that that's what because
if it's not I guarantee you somebody in
a PR room is like trust me this is what
you're gonna say Matt really what it is
exactly that's exactly what you did
you're going to shed tears as you wrote
it no no it's the ashtray that Bruce
Wayne made when he was seven that he
gave to his parents the night before
they no no no not that no no no it was
made from the pearls that brown stomach
no it was the Revlon hair dryer that he
used to use
oh no no not that blender yeah
no no so I'm excited about it I I'm
still I'm still waiting for
I have loved all of the Batman movies
all of them well okay
I have loved aspects of all of the
Batman movies aspects I there was one
Batman movie that yeah I was glad that
there was a Batman movie and then of all
the other movies I have enjoyed all of
them but I have never felt like like
like like the concept of Batman movie
has been made and so and so I and and so
I love all of these all of these
different versions because because
because they're things that I absolutely
love about because how can you not love
Batman and but but still I'm kind of
waiting for from my the one where I'm
like this does this does it offer and so
I you know what if the crystal penis
ends up being the dude who walks up
there and and in in in is the Bruce
Wayne of all our dreams then I might go
for it I'm excited for a second I
thought like crystal penis which is like
CIA code word or some are just I'm just
imagining you know like Edward running
around in the woods you know you know
you know sparkled on its bark sparkling
and just just just just you know free as
a bird no I'm like that's gonna hurt man
chase I have to imagine don't leave a
mark that's all I'm saying
getting buff that yeah yeah so I'm yeah
I'm really excited about about you know
what comes next as am i speaking of
Batman I'm trying to find a way to link
all these stories just wait okay you do
it I had been working with with Kevin
for a stretch on Masters of the Universe
oh yeah
which was a blast like had the most fun
ever and like I had known he had sent me
a text you know a couple months ago with
like dude here's who I think is gonna be
the voice cast and I was like
[ __ ] you there won't allow me in
their presence like I'm not getting
invited to the cast and crew party cuz
like half of them I should have a
restraining order again right right
because I love them all too much it was
lazy I won't tell them who you are it'll
be fine
and then on Valentine's Day Netflix
released the voice cast for this it's
[ __ ] banana it's crazy it's so crazy
alright I'm gonna read some of these
names sure sure I read them all real
real one because I did not type them all
and yet I will still know exactly
because you cut and pasted all of these
names hard work it is they ran together
a little bit I'm not gonna lie I was
like wait where does the character start
and I got the carpel from doing it all
of it I got the power I can do this
Marc [ __ ] Hamel is playing Skeletor
oh my god oh [ __ ] I thought all I was
ever gonna get out of Skeletor was
amazing Geico commercials and the idea
that Mark Hamill is going to be doing he
bad bastards in the universe is just too
good so [ __ ] crazy Lena Headey is
evil in [ __ ] Cersei Lannister ballina
Chris Wood from Supergirl is Prince Adam
slash he-man nice Sarah Michelle [ __ ]
Gellar is Teela awesome liam Cunningham
[ __ ] the The Onion Knight Onion
Knight man-at-arms mana mana dog's was
always my face you know why because he
was my first action figure yeah he was
my because yeah I don't know if you
remember about the but the toys came out
before the show came out oh yeah and I
was like man at arms that dude's got all
these weapons he's gonna kick so much
ass I have never been so frustrated with
a TV show in my life
I mean it was just week after week of
him not doing a [ __ ] thing
well Adam we'll get through this somehow
I'm gonna go shave my mustache something
I will say I think we fixed that for you
man I'm so excited he does like two
things okay you know what
that's more that you know what literally
200 200 percent more than the bill I
have ever seen in my life
just for you let Steven root from office
space nice as Cringer is Cringer
Dietrich Bader is king Ram ya trap-jaw
griffin Newman as Orko friend of the
podcast Tiffany Smith is andr love it
Henry goddamn Rollins as tricot Henry
Rollins I was once on her on a plane
sitting next to Henry Rollins in it and
I just I just sat there dad I was just
like this is the best day ever story
exactly just just tell me a story about
how you rip your shirt off and save the
world and couldn't tell anybody you know
Black Flag alan oppenheimer
who was the original Skeletor and I is a
moss man no he was in West world he was
in West world Susan Eisenberg Susan
Eisenberg the Wonder Woman of Wonder
Woman the wonder what do I miss playing
sorceress at least see a silver stone
from the nipples Batman and Robin that's
true that's true it's just how I go to
the nipples movie where every bachelor
had nipples for reasons that I just also
remember that when he put on his pants
they they they like like clamped on so
that we could see his butt see the the
butt day and I was just like how do you
how do you put those how do you walk in
those pants
I remember lunch that's also the Batman
movie where we're Alfred to boot up some
computer program puts a bat disc in a CD
player and then scratches it like he's a
DJ was that the one I thought that was
I thought that was a forever I think
that was Batman the second Tim Burton
Batman Batman Returns in return yeah
yeah I think that was bad memory and I
think that was that that was actually
yeah yeah no and it was and I believe it
was Michael Keaton doing that I'm not I
think it might have been was it [ __ ]
Michael Keaton you know why you know
what because this is one of those times
where where I was I if I was in college
or I was in in high school and it was on
HBO or Showtime and it played 400 times
and so I watched that movie more times
than I can think I will just say cocaine
is a hell of a drug it is it's true yes
yes I have a jheri curl in those days so
many bad decisions okay Lisa Silverstone
is Queen Marlena Justin long nice Jason
Mewes as stink or Phil the great film
the mama as hero awesome tony todd then
scare glow can course
oh man again increase summer as
priestess mmm Kevin Michael Richardson
as beast man all right Kevin [ __ ]
Conroy as Merman oh nice and one Harley
Quinn Smith as Elena that that cast is
[ __ ] bonkers man that is awesome I
don't I don't know what to do it I'm
telling you it like this you know what
house it's gonna be crazy
I'm just glad that I didn't know who was
playing these characters when I was
writing my episode because there's like
oh [ __ ] let me give the onion item [ __ ]
did say I got a feeling there is there
they're gonna be so far from whoever you
think they sound like you know what I
mean it's gonna be incredible it's gonna
be incredible and also it's like hey so
when are they recording the lines from
my episode I'm gonna just swerve on out
there
really sure you've got to check that out
how you doing Buffy now you go here you
read dad right you got that [ __ ] I know
you sub sir see kill it sir
this is such a crazy cast it's amazing I
don't understand any of it it's gonna be
awesome
you know what he-man brings two people
together really do you know what I mean
he has the power he has the power and
you know how yeah you know you had the
power because they met in that show he
ran and jumped and did like a little a
little somersault you know roll and then
kept running again in every episode of
he-man Masters of the Universe there was
that one that one moment where he would
he would be running and doing some
action thing but it was the same goddamn
moment for four years well once and then
what and they were like natural C
control V just do that [ __ ] everybody
every time that is powerful yeah to do
that like for four years running it just
keep us intoxicated so he's got to get
from this place to that place how we
gonna do that Walt you know he's gonna
do it right jump slide boom we use it
every day
cuz that's how we make the he-man time
to make him wrong
were you a Lucifer fan on The WB and now
on not the WB like there's still a
[ __ ] channel yeah honestly it's one
of those shows that I never never got
around to watching I've met Lucifer
himself he's a handsome devil is what
are you - [ __ ] handsome exactly like
it's a problem how handsome ridiculously
handsome like here I do this other
podcast called the Battlestar Galactica
with Tricia Helfer
and we're watching every episode of
Battlestar Galactica and so we've had a
couple of like friends of the show come
on the podcast and and she said oh yeah
Tom Ellis is gonna be our guest on this
episode it's like okay cool recording 11
o'clock in the morning whatever it's
fine
[ __ ] shows up clearly just woke
up looking like the [ __ ] Prince of
England I mean like his his hair was
just tussle yeah just [ __ ] right
damn accent I swear to God like maybe
hadn't showered in two days but it still
smelt like [ __ ] musk oh absolutely
like I'm starting to feel some [ __ ] like
you know just like smokes so now he
smells like it's like how do you walk
through the world like this
yeah easily that's how he does it yeah
like not fair yeah exactly
what do you desire everything you want
me to it's like John Hamm and 30 rock
people just giving him [ __ ] on the
street exactly are you a doctor no witch
here you are now it was and also like I
should not be in rooms with people like
that attempt to maintain some sense of
self oh no now is what I just go and eat
all the Twinkies and a gun because too
much but you made it but you made it and
and apparently believe I'm here and
Lucifer which had been supposedly only
gonna go five seasons Netflix had picked
them up after the after Fox had canceled
it they went a season then they went
another like half a season right and
then like I were done psyched and so now
they're coming back they're in
negotiations to do one more year of
Lucifer on Netflix could hear perhaps
made a deal with the devil
that's so exciting man as exciting I
mean because I've had a young justice
was one of the shows that that uh that
I've been a part of for a long time we
we did it for two years it got cancelled
and because of fan support Netflix and
everything was raised from the dead and
came back you know the you know for some
reason I haven't lost my head or
anything uh they were walking I mean I'm
on I'm on all of all of these you know
odd shows that like Teen Titans that you
know we did five fabulous seasons you
know and then it's supposed to be over
and you never hear from it again and
then and then and then we do a couple of
shorts you know two years later and then
a year after that we start doing Teen
Titans go and then and then people
remember that that I was okay at doing
cyborg and then I do cyborgs and all of
these different animations so uh so
there is something lovely about the
world we're living in now that that
people are dying for that content and
and nothing's truly dead if some if we
still really loved it and and and
there's something beautiful about about
nostalgia and and and having that that
power as a people you know when
something is truly great to never never
have to let it go you can always find it
it's beautiful
I feel like that's what Captain Kirk
said it's Fox funeral in Rafic on like
never met anyone so juban human he's
never really gone as long as we remember
absolutely well done
I'm excited for it to come back because
I like that show quite a bit it is not
it's funny like I like the Lucifer comic
book the Neil Gaiman Lucifer book that
came out from vertigo and the shows not
bad and it took a little while for me to
adjust to the fact that one was not
going to necessarily have to be the
other right and it found its own stride
and it became super [ __ ] fun and the
cast gels really well with each other
and it just became a I kind of want to
have a good time right like I don't want
to be taxed by it I don't want to be
thinking too hard about it
not that it's like not very well done
and not that the crimes and it's a
procedural it's police procedural right
it is the only one of those I
because I just I like the people in it
and there's something to be said for
like I can go and watch that show and
feel comforted by people that I'm
familiar with and and that is no small
thing that's cool I mean a in a crazily
fractured entertainment landscape with
us 500 TV shows on exactly and that's
the thing you know what and this this
conversation is gonna give me you know
is my literally if I had if I wasn't
watching birds of prey because I was I
had flown back into town yesterday or
actually on Sunday and so no no it was
early Monday and and I was and and I was
gonna go see birds of prey yesterday and
I was gonna start watch I was gonna
watch a few episodes of Lucifer today
just just with it it's so this is
literally my introduction I'm excited to
check it out it's worth it yeah you know
and I don't imagine you will hate
yourself looking at Tommy oh I won't
hate myself I you that's fine if you
yeah if you [ __ ] this up for me but I
got a feeling you know we got a similar
vibe yeah it's gonna be fine me yeah you
know what hate me in person how much
follow you home I got no place to sleep
exactly what's in the fridge I can only
chickpeas were you as I was as I'm
imagining most of us were and still are
[ __ ] nuts didn't die he just
disappeared for a while a Rick Moranis
fan of course are you kidding me
yeah like there's there's so much of my
childhood that is like Rick Moranis
based absolutely and and then he kind of
just like up and disappeared a while ago
you know what there's something
beautiful about it about someone in this
business who disappears of their own
volition
you know who has has enough success to
be able to take care of his in his own
and it's like you know what I'm gonna
take that time I'm gonna I'm gonna enjoy
you know my family and everything and
that's that's what what uh pretty much
what he did right
I get around like the the late 90s he
was just like you know what I don't want
to do this anymore
yeah he's gonna want to raise my kids
I'm gonna have my life I want to live in
the middle of some places not LA and
just [ __ ] you know be me and then
you're right there's something super
Admiral about like he found a piece
right live in that piece exactly I mean
you do Sigourney Weaver you shrink up a
couple of kids you get the hell out of
town what more can you what you were
already a giant dog I'm telling you
Disney managed to pull him out of his
sanctum sanctorum and and drag him out
of retirement to go and do another Honey
I Shrunk the what Evers right movies for
like a full-on [ __ ] theatrical movie
not like Disney Plus now and I'm like
I'm torn on it because again like that
do did he had already gone to his
Valhalla right he was like listen man I
found my warriors respite and I'm like
knitting or making [ __ ] honey or like
masonry
whatever his hobbies listen if Daniel
day-lewis has taught us anything okay
it's that actors truly being retired is
some [ __ ] okay that jug has been
retired more times than Daniel day-lewis
I think I think bridge do it more than
anybody Hopkins has been retired like
every third year is that I'm [ __ ]
done with this right hey man would you
like to play Odin again yes I would of
course you would because that you know
because the truth is the thing about a
think thing about acting is is that is
that you don't really retire from acting
because because the job of acting is
getting the job the job of actually
doing the acting that's not work even
when it's hard it's not work it is the
best feeling you could possibly have as
as in as an artist as because because
because all they're asking is that you
you take that piece of yourself that
piece of yourself deep down and just be
honest and give it it's just about
giving at the end of the day and sir and
so when somebody asks an actor to get
out
retirement it's it's just about giving
that that piece of yourself and and and
that the hard part is is getting from
Burbank to Santa Monica the hard part is
sitting here and talking to people you
don't want to talk to the hard part is
all this are [ __ ] exactly I'm sorry
the hard part is all of that but the but
but but at the end of the day the acting
itself the the point of that is the you
never really get give up that because
the truth is is is is you're living that
on a daily basis
you're still a storyteller you know you
never stop being that you know and so on
and so I'm excited for him because I
because that because he wouldn't come
back if he didn't really want to and I
and and he gets to go back there's a
great white north when he's done you
know very nice thank you
alright last last story and it's less a
story just more I'm kind of psyched for
this thing to exist is that there's a
low-key show we all know there's a
low-key show right Gugu mbatha-raw is
joining the cast of Loki I love which
suddenly makes it like 25 percent more
thing I was gonna have to have in my
eyes soon because I'm that listen like
there was a chance I had I was working
for the LA Times and and she made some
movie it wasn't very good this free
state of Jones movie with Michael
Michael Matthew McConaughey some like
Civil War thing which whatever but they
were like hey do you want to interviewer
and I said is there a word that is both
no and yes at the same time yeah because
yes she's fascinating and she's got a
really interesting career and then no I
can't be in a room with somebody who
looks like that all the time
and then me just be this [ __ ] troll
who like walks through the world like
jeans that don't fit right like I think
it's bad for me did you pull it together
though no no no second time I did that
Oh brah I had a chance to interview age
yourself and for the same reason I was
like can't do it I can't like walk in
there realizing that we are both a the
same species and be the same age
hahaha how did these two things [ __ ]
happen and I like carry on with my life
after that oh I gotta I gotta be able to
hold my head up and not just be like oh
it could have been that I gotta
appreciate the honesty though I mean you
know what you know what if if any of us
can know anything in this world know
that so no that's so no those rooms you
can walk into and then walk out of some
semblance of yourself intact oh my god
who's 200 rooms that I could not have
escaped from like a little life I hear
you awesome well this is this is amazing
this is amazing I'm all for it
absolutely absolutely if we can if we
can inject more black people into Norse
mythology way to stand here we go I will
cut that out
JC we're cutting the Cosby bit just
nobody needs that yeah
and we're back that'll be like everybody
at homes gonna be like what did they cut
out and then you'll be like I will need
to know give use in the house this is
where you buy tickets cuz you have to
see what we cut out we're like we don't
want the world to see them and we're bad
we'll just keep doing that all we got
this that is all the news that is fit to
print my friend that is exciting that is
exciting and so now we come to the part
of the show that is my favorite part of
the show JC did you give me the magic
tickets you pulled out from under the
[ __ ] keg in the back and was a weird
the secret hiding spot or is like I
swear their tickets back here somewhere
what kind of picture do you have on
these what's happening that's these
people okay
okay they have clothes on I was
wondering what's happening here it's
it's they're they're all they're wearing
beige everybody's wearing beige it's the
Hedgehog cinema yeah
nobody's that close on thanks to our
good friends at Brett deacon at 40 X and
screen X we have tickets to hand out for
people who ask us the best questions
that both of us can answer so ask me
nothing about CG Tigers maybe don't ask
him anything about carnivore oh that's
me you can ask me one question about
carnival rope it's sure did you watch it
no I did watch carnival rules yes I did
man you you put on you put some fairies
in anything I'm gonna watch it we almost
got there yes so MJ see our man behind
the spotlight we'll pick out some handy
victims to ask you some questions oh hey
man hey how's it going guys good good
good what's your name my name is her
root her root first off Mysterio Peyton
thank you very much for coming in to our
wonderful lair oh yeah man thank you for
having me I love you shark man
thank you got the Funko store I love it
so my question is what type of show or
movie would you like to see being repo
in today's time and I will give you my
perfect example of today's time that we
really need see rebooted shoot well
what's yours you know what's your first
off I definitely would like to see a new
Captain Planet reboot because in this
time what we're seeing right now we need
to see what's been going on with climate
change and hold these deniers who are
saying that's not true but we know the
real truth right Captain Planet all
right
everything carts in live-action it's
open d all the above I I would kind of
dig a bionic man I think I think that
there's there was a great issue of a
comic book series called global
frequency which if you've never read
it's [ __ ] phenomena Warren Ellis a
bunch of rotating artists but it was
like a 10th ology every issue was a
different story
but they did one issue who about which
is fundamentally the bionic man who the
implants didn't take right and it's like
what happens when your body's not your
boss
what happens when you wake up and you
look in the mirror and you don't see
that you that you used to see like what
does it do to your mind when you're not
the version of yourself that you're most
familiar with until that sense of we are
we are as a society as a culture is all
of it
beginning to incorporate far more alien
materials into our bodies I be like
implants or or replacements or upgrades
or skin grafts or I got our titanium hip
oh yeah I gotta this thing Oh at what
point does it become I'm no longer than
me that I used to know and some of it is
not by my desire you know like the [ __ ]
that happens to Steve Austin was not his
choice like he went down in a [ __ ]
accident and woke up with this [ __ ] in
his body and what is your perspective on
that stuff as a person and then you're
asked to like do superheroes [ __ ] like
oh now you're a secret agent like
[ __ ] I can't recognize my feet
and you're telling me I gotta go and
like defuse an atom bomb somewhere like
I think that that the the core question
that every character is wrestling with
and anything is Who am I why am I here
and what do I want and if that person's
very sense of himself is so [ __ ] up
beyond recognition those questions get
really really interesting like what do I
want do I want to not be this anymore do
I want to do good with this tour I want
to do bad with this like what happens to
your moral compass
once you're no longer yourself so I
would watch that show I would also make
that show Hollywood give me money and
I'll make your show for you that's mine
I feel so Kevin right now yeah so
[ __ ] Kevin just want to crawl
underneath this scum and villainy bar
and try and just Constanza exactly just
sits down here with all the droids that
they won't let out
I'm tryna it right right it's like I'm
cyborg really shut up man just wait for
everybody to go home so we can get the
[ __ ] out of here
oh man uh let's see I have um I only
have like joke ideas like Manimal dude
don't [ __ ] joke dude I would watch
man I love Manimal growing up I was I
literally was I remember when when when
Manimal got canceled and I was like how
did Bill get canceled
he turns into like four things I was
like everybody's watching this show
obviously it's on my TV every set for
Friday or Saturday or whatever the hell
it is is we had nothing else to do so
they could do like Friday at 8:00 we're
like I'm all right exactly
everybody's watching Manimal how could
they possibly have canceled this this
this juggernaut of a popularity mccorkin
bill needs to work dude yeah I remember
when he was like he was like I can't
turn into a panther so I need to I need
to go to a martial artist who's gonna
teach me the Panther style and see he
would roll around and be like you know
and then finally bought by the end of it
he was like I could turn into a panther
I used to love it cuz Stan Winston did
all the effect yeah and so like and it
was very much like the he-man were
tucking and rolling yeah every time he
turned everything it was the same
[ __ ] footage like I'm a hawk same
Hawk footage look like a [ __ ] these
fingers which is the longest its paws
paws happening same [ __ ] power
footage same snake footage all about it
oh my god yeah so no I mean honestly I
love me some animal and I love crimes
that can only be solved by a dude who
turns into animals
it's a very Miche sort of Detective
Agency he is one call a year exactly but
that you know some dude stole my Panther
can maybe you find it of course I can
that'll be two hundred and fifty
thousand dollars
yes so one job a year yes so so Manimal
i you know it's a joke but not really I
stand by that I would like to see man so
like you remember mantis I would I would
like to be mantis I feel like I would
have a better run than mantis had mantis
had this crazy man just run and I just
every time you I was like this is so
awesome this is go stop running stop
running mantis why are you running like
that I mean to be fair I was running
like a mantis he was right he was
running like a dude who had me run in
like 15 years because he was like a
paraplegic it's true like clearly he's
not gonna Jesse Owens that [ __ ] cuz now
you Jesse Owens it again you know what
you you know what we have suspended our
disbelief at this point you can just see
Owens that [ __ ] maybe Carl Laemmle was
not a good runner you know you know what
I'm not gonna blame it on him
i'ma blame it on a stuntman blame it on
a stuntman but but but yes yes mantis I
would I would love a good mantis reboot
you know okay and while we're at it you
know what if I'm gonna get let's if
we're gonna get on this [ __ ] do it
misfits of science do you remember
misfits of science you being saucy I'm
sorry man I'm going back to child
I'm going back to baby times misfits of
science you know - dude would you don't
win he would I did that the tall guy who
would get real little and then the UH
and the dude who would grab there grab
the the electricity and he could shoot
for a little bit and Courtney Cox
whether they actually I can't remember
what she did but she was very Courtney
Cox she did yeah that said that um yeah
yeah that Springsteen little Bob haircut
absolutely Courtney Cox and people
around here doing misfits of science of
basically it's like listen guys I just
wanted the 1986 NBC lineup exactly
exactly Greatest American Hero
I want to do Greatest American Hero can
I do - American Hero oh my god I can
grow the hair I swear to you give me
like give me give me 18 months I can do
it believe it or not I can do it in the
hair yes I would watch that in a [ __ ]
heartbeat boom oh you know what I was
always I was like I was like he can't be
that bad at flying the entire app you
know you know run of the show at some
point he's got to even that [ __ ] out you
know just stop swatting flies the whole
time you know let's have a progression
this is gonna get better right he's
always like the kid who just learned how
to ride his bike yeah like and then
apparently forgets that he just learned
how to ride his bike every time total
amnesia that's the part of the show we
didn't really get yeah I was like I was
like he's gonna be better this episode
no retro and amnesia now every [ __ ]
episode like what happened we just wiped
him clean it's true it's true you shoot
himself in that suit you forgot how to
do that - man I thought I had no answers
apparently I got answers so there we go
do we answer the question sir absolutely
excellent thanks come and get some
tickets man come and get you tickets
[Applause]
[Music]
Thank You Man hey what's your name
Marcus Ortiz I just came out here from
New York I listen to the show all the
time coming out as of right now you have
you windy I was farthest away before I
came so good job what part of New York I
lived now in Westchester but I grew up
in the Bronx
buggy down represent nice welcome aboard
so this is actually sort of along those
lines thinking about how hip-hop culture
has sort of you know proliferated into
media the intersection between nerd
culture and sort of minority hip hop
cultures emerging even with like your
influence on Miles Morales and other
takes but it's still sort of not really
a thing yet so I guess it's more of a I
got a story I got a story I have to tell
you about Miles Morales I got a story I
gotta tell you about Miles Morales right
now I got to tell you right now you stay
right there there's a good story because
I mean I was meaning to like tell you
about this in a more private setting but
[ __ ] it we're here am I gonna cry no no
it's just I'm a crying okay I may cry or
then I would have cried okay and then
she so and then it could be a whole
[ __ ] thing
it's so it's so crazy man okay so six
years ago I did this this pilot of of
powers before powers the the the Sony
Playstation show came out they did they
did one for FX powers and that's when I
met Brian Michael Bendis and that was
right as literally there were there were
like you know Fox you know was was all
up in arms that the Spider Man was gonna
be black and and all of this in the in
the comic books and everything and and I
was I was right riding with Brian
Michael Bendis and this is literally
like the greatest things ever happened
in my life it's it's it's a tiniest
little thing because I grew up I grew up
Spiderman was my favorite by far he was
he was you know everything marvel to me
because because he wasn't bigger than
life he was he was he was this tiny
little I mean not Muslim but but uh
Peter Parker tiny skinny little kid but
when he put the mask on he would I was
shy growing up believe it or not I was
shy growing up but if I got on a stage
if I got on a son I came alive and I
love spider-man for that
because he was just a nerdy little kid
he put that that thing all of a sudden
he had the quips he could do all the
stuff and I and he was skinny like me it
was like it was like I was I could be in
that suit and when I was a kid I would
tell my Brian Michael Bendis when we
were when we were driving to set he was
like man I'm getting all of this
blowback you know all of these people
are talking [ __ ] about about this
character and and I said and I said you
you have you have done this incredible
thing for me and I and and I just want
to tell you just keep doing what you're
doing don't listen to anybody because
because when I was on the playground and
they'd be like you can't be Superman you
can't be Batman because they're blood
they're they're white they're they're
whiter they're they're so they're that
and I was like fine I'm spider-man and
they were like they were like you can't
be spider-man I was like yeah you don't
know who spider-man is you don't know
he's spider-man with Winnie when he puts
that thing on because anybody can wear
that mask I can be that man anybody can
wear that man and and that's what I told
Brian Michael Bendis years ago I forgot
all about that conversation and then I
read an article when Brian Michael
Bendis was talking about Miles Morales
and he was and they were talking about
this movie that was coming out
spider-man into the spider-verse
and he was like well I was uh you know
we've been working on this thing and and
I years ago you may not you know know
this guy but he does these cartoons and
I was having a conversation with this
guy Khary Payton when we were coming out
with Miles Morales and he said anybody
can wear the mask I'm about to cry right
now
[Applause]
the point is you never know you never
know who you talk to
what what what you say or do I have I'm
sure I have affected many people on many
levels because I've met them all my life
but to me do ever to have affected even
in the tiniest I actually didn't affect
anything I just I just said go forward
what you're doing is right go forward
that's that's all I did but but but I
did it for the character that I grew up
seeing in myself more than anyone and
and and to intuit I can't even remember
who sent me that that article I think
was just somebody was sending me on
Twitter and and I sat there and tears
ran down my face and I thought I thought
to myself I thought to myself this is
all I got into this business for you
know was that I could that I could
affect somebody and then they in turn
affect me back but I just are knowing
your whole story with with Miles Morales
and and I and and when I read I was i I
was like one day I'm gonna tell him this
story and and just how much it's a it's
a affected me so beautiful there it is
that's beautiful thank you yeah like you
never [ __ ] know
and listen you never know who's gonna
get touched you never know how they're
gonna get touched and then every now and
again you just plant the seeds man it my
mom years ago I was struggling as in as
an actor and my mom was like why don't
you just go back to doing theater and do
something else because because I you
know you seemed you were you were happy
doing that I was like I'm happy now mom
I'm happy with the struggle and it was
the and she didn't understand because
she wasn't seeing me on the big screen
or on TV you know I was just doing like
you know guest star stuff and you know
commercials here and there and and and
and and I said I said mom I just feel
like there's somebody that needs to see
me
that's in a bigger space than this this
little room
I think it needs to be projected there's
somebody that I'm never gonna meet who I
need to tell something to and they're
gonna hear it because I'm telling it cuz
I can tell it the way nobody else can
and and and that thought has always
driven me in those in this rollercoaster
of a [ __ ] I've been doing this for
twenty something years you know and and
and the thing that keeps me going is
there's one person in a dark room
watching a lit up box
flashing back at them cuz they need it
it's it I mean yeah it's entertainment
but but but we needed somebody's talking
to us through that box you know and I
and that's the thing that keeps us going
and and and and and that's the thing
that I always think about and at the end
the end the the truth is is thankfully
because of the Walking Dead I'm able to
do all of these conventions and things
and you know the difference is on stage
you get that immediate gratification the
beauty of those conventions is that
people come and they finally tell you
you know I mean cancer to survivors
people with depression all of it they're
the one that I remember the most there
was this huge dude he had a big bushy
beard and a big big white guy and I was
like okay here comes my walking dead guy
you know he want you want some and he
pushed over this cyborg picture you know
and and and then I looked in his face
and I saw he was a young guy he had a
big beard but he was a young dude you
know and he was like this got through me
through a lot of bad times of my life I
don't I don't know what it was but uh
but but his big old arms came out like
this you don't pick me up and I will
never forget that hug you know cuz I
don't know what he's gone through I
don't know if he's gone through but it
got him to it got him to meet me to this
this place that we are that's what we
[ __ ] do man that's what we [ __ ] do
and and and anyway Miles Morales
I'm glad to start my question got to
tell that story that's amazing - brother
- you know so similar to Miles Morales
and maybe thinking of like a Miles
Morales - I'll give you an example of
something like for me that was sort of
didn't expect it and then when I saw it
was amazing
back in the 90s New York undercover on
Fox was an amazing show took over what
was the typical cop procedural and
certainly gave it a different
perspective on it so for both of you you
as an actor and you as a writer
what's a property that you think either
could be you know taken from hip-hop
culture a minority culture and brought
into a sort of more of a science-fiction
realm or the vice-versa taking something
like a spider-man and bringing it into a
more of a hip-hop take on it and then
bonus points if you can think of an
artist that might be able to score it oh
okay so a thing so basically want me to
Hamilton something right like find a
thing that doesn't inherently feel like
it belongs in hip-hop and then bring it
into that sphere or vice versa this is
some homework type [ __ ] you know what
I'm gonna go first because you gonna
give you a second because thank you
because actually I've already sort of
done something like this it has and so
yeah so I'm cheating and I may be like
out in a little something but but who
cares we we all friends here don't tell
nobody
so so the cool thing about Teen Titans
go is that is that we have we have
garnered enough success that nobody
cares what we do anymore they kind of
didn't care what we did before anyway
but they really don't care now because
because when we went off the rails is
when we started to really find things
and so and so fortunately for me the the
the showrunner of the show now Pete
Rider Michael and I
are huge fans of the of the hip-hop
group
De La Soul from like way back in a day
and if you don't know about De La Soul
it's hard to find their their old stuff
because they are there they have a beef
with the with the the people who own the
property to their to their to their
music three feet high and rising
refilled with so many [ __ ] samples
that it's impossible for you like it's
yes it was that one in Paul's Boutique
yeah which basically caused them to
write laws about sample literally
brought wrote laws about sampling and so
and so I and so they've been in in
litigation trying to get this worked out
forever and so and so Pete like I was
frustrated that we couldn't get to the
music and we wanted to write a Teen
Titans go episode about fighting for
that music and we were like we wrote it
you know and and Pete wrote an episode
about De La Soul and the only problem is
is that you had to get we had to get De
La Soul to do it so we called up De La
Soul and man hello della yeah and yeah
yeah we were we were looking for the sol
de la that is and de la answered to
answer the phone they they all flew down
here that we they and doug and before
you know it i mean it is we've done
music before but never something with a
hip-hop bent you know we've done the
night begins to shine and and definitely
done some 80's rock opera kind of things
and so we've taken that rock opera and
we've we've melted it with hip-hop and
so you will see De La Soul in your
future that's [ __ ] amazing alright so
I'm about to get in so much trouble VIP
I don't care man
and we're bad
[Laughter]
part of me thinks that like what what
what are the defining at least from me
the defining pillars of hip-hop is
overwhelming confidence right like every
every rapper every emcee who's coming
out the gate is going to tell you why
they're so [ __ ] awesome like that's
that's that is the unifying thread that
connects everybody from [ __ ] ll to
[ __ ] run DMC to you know Jay Z like
everybody said I'm the [ __ ] best
there's this book that I'm pretty sure
it's like 400 years old by now if not
older yeah 300 years old I called the
three musketeers which is fundamentally
about a character named d'Artagnan who
thinks he's better than [ __ ]
everybody else is like he swans into
this town like I'm gonna get this petty
revenge for this thing and I'm with a
duel this dude who's better than I am
and this dude who I'm better than and
this dude and it's just about duels some
of us do to get himself like trouble
with dueling a bunch of people and he
thinks he could beat them all he
schedules them like right after each
other cuz he knows he's gonna survive it
and this [ __ ] sword fighting and
there's [ __ ] derring-do and there's a
[ __ ] you know countess and the evil
[ __ ] priest all of that [ __ ] but I
think there's a version of that that's
[ __ ] hip-hop I think there's a
version of that that that sense of I
came into this city thinking I'm better
than [ __ ] everybody else and here's
I'm going to be both humbled by it and
prove my worth by doing it I wish that
you could get the Beastie Boys to do
that alas we have no more Beastie Boys
so that's what that you can't have I
love you so much I didn't I didn't know
it until this moment but I love you so
much for you to bring you to bring the
[ __ ] three musketeers and hip hop
together I hope you don't mind man but
I'm just I'm gonna sleep on your couch
tonight
because because I mean honestly the the
only thing that you and this this is
what may made me even more excited
because because that is an amazing idea
and literally my favorite that the
reason that I wanted to become an actor
was because in the first grade I went to
see a community theater production of of
oh god what was it it leaving me isn't
it his name is no no no his white plume
he's no no no no no good lord how do I
live literally literally they like like
and the idea that the three musketeers
or Cyrano I mean he's so money
he's so money and doesn't he I'm in and
he is so confident about everything
every [ __ ] thing except that woman
except that woman
he has supreme confidence he he will
literally win a war single-handedly
but he cannot talk to this woman it's
his cousin I don't know why they put
that in there that was weird
that was weird that was [ __ ] up I
don't know why who's my age just go for
it man
like take a dip in his gene pool son I'm
telling you Ruxin but but uh but yeah
yeah I mean those those swords that
confidence that's beautiful you know I
mean it's it's the thing that that I
loved about that Baz Luhrmann version of
Romeo and Juliet which is like we're
dueling but they're not really duels
like we got we got so we are rapiers but
that's the make of a gun it's like
recontextualizing the thing that we
already know to be there in a different
way and yeah just [ __ ] this this dude
from [ __ ] Georgia comes into Harlem
and like wants to [ __ ] sway and has to
go up against the three MCS that [ __ ]
hold it down ya know that's amazing
that's super [ __ ] yeah I love that I
love
yeah literally my favorite Leonardo
DiCaprio moment is when when he he takes
Tibbles gun and puts it on his forehead
and dares and dares him with tears in
his eyes
you know it was like it's not about the
fight you know it's not about the fight
in here it's about the fight up here
that's the first time I saw Harold
Perrineau in anything oh wow and and his
prints of is so beautiful when he's like
you know because he gets [ __ ] stabbed
show about to die and he's like you know
ask for me tomorrow you'll find me a
grave man and he's like smiling through
it all because he knows that he just did
this for his brother for his friend and
doesn't even want to tell him that he's
dying but he still can't keep it a
secret sure it was that [ __ ] wordplay
it breaks my heart every time so good
so good so that then Tim is what I do
but [ __ ] great question man great
question great question repping the
boogie down come if you're still in town
go see a movie
hi how you doing oh my gosh I'm a little
nervous
start laboratory Yousef you say yeah
well I love both of you guys really a
lot and I've really made an effort to
come out here cuz I thank you so much
man like mark your journalism like talk
about like black culture and like media
and everything like that really made me
think about my own culture you know I'm
Arabic and I think of how that reflect
on like so media itself because you know
everyone that looks like me wants to
like blow up this country so I was like
but of course that's changing you know
but like I just I just love your
journalism skills I love your writing I
love the way how you articulate things
and like the importance of everything
else and I just like love reading you
like to death and even love the episodes
that you write as well and television is
like extraordinary and khari like I feel
like I never really truly became a fan
of you until T Titans go just because
like it showcase more of your range like
in one episode you could be like a
preacher of the gospel of TV and another
episode you could be the childlike
wondering why you're so adorable
just like you constantly questions that
it's just like it's just like you as an
actor just like showed so much you know
just like man this guy could like do
anything and I'm a huge fan of Young
Justice so like everything and all the
twenty characters you're playing Young
Justice just like yeah so like my
question I guess it's a bit of a
challenging run right for both of you I
was always wondering like mark if you
were to create a character that car you
could play what what kind of character
would he be as his car since you're a
writer you could like you know jump in
and like you know help him with this and
like what would what kind of cash phrase
require who could deliver and I would
love to hear that catchphrase coming out
of your catchphrase catchphrase where's
my hasta LaVista baby wait wait
do I do I need to write a catchphrase
for for mark if you want you just work
so I gotta go back you know I gotta
create a character that you can play
with a catchphrase and then maybe you
got a good catchphrase for the character
that you're gonna write for me to play
hmm all right I know the catchphrase
you know the catchphrase the catchphrase
here's the thing I don't have the
catchphrase yet but I have I have the
beginnings of a character okay
see that's where I'm falling down yeah
yeah Mike Mike and here's the way they
it's the beginnings of a character the
character is you're a you're an
Orchestrator okay of like music like a
conductor or know what but it's you play
an organ okay that guy that was weird
you play a a piano device okay all right
I swear to god you people that I that
when you play it like like the tendrils
of the other sound like like have an
influence on the world that's but I'm
but I'm still working on the on the
catchphrase
because right now it's melodic it's not
okay you know because I got the
catchphrase and I don't want to give up
the catchphrase I'm just gonna find a
way to get all right you know what [ __ ]
it give it to me write what you know
you're a you're a struggling writer a
struggling playwright I love it
who has this one idea that you can't
seem to get any traction on how'd you
know but you're you you keep on like
getting closer and closer and closer but
there's there's something about you
that's unwilling to compromise that idea
that that causes you to slide back down
so it's a little bit of a Sisyphus ian
like i could i could do this if you just
let me do it the way I know I need to do
it and then your catchphrase is because
your friends are all like do just
[ __ ] take the money just take the
money dude just [ __ ] get that thing
up there and you keep on saying I won't
do it until I know it's right and then
one works right I'm gonna make that
white boy money make that white boy
money son I love it I love it I love it
I'd make them almost like a production
company that yeah yeah this is like
hello white boy money wave Oh money
absolutely boy money Hey I have your
catchphrase okay I have your catchphrase
oh okay because you're your characters
is this person who is he's he's in a
it's it's not a church but it's like a
church because you're you've got got
this organ these pipes are fill and you
and when you play it it I it influences
something out there somewhere and and
you sit in front of this this instrument
and and and I see whoever is needing
your help
you know they've come they finally found
you and they have to explain to you you
know what you have
to do in order to I you know what they
need what needs to change what happens
and they're and they're kind of yelling
at you telling you trying to convince
you and I and you tell them you tell
them finally leave me alone just let me
play that's cool just let me play just
let me play I feel like that's what they
need to do man you need to somebody
needs to give you a deal and just let
you play alright alright I'll take my
money absolutely I mean you can cast me
we can both make that white boy money
excellent does that answer your question
yes it does I believe come on get it
come on down I got some tickets
alright we got one last set of tickets
hello hello camper mr. Rhyne funk how
are you pretty well how are you guys I
know Ryan from the internet okay he
works on the walking dead oh yeah you've
got you got a yeah yeah those those
sweaters don't come did they have their
that the thumb holes yeah yeah Joe all
right
he works in the writing staff okay very
good very good and the room where
happens also this [ __ ] hold on
before we get into this question I am he
are also we bonded over Hamilton right
nice and because why wouldn't you yes
and then when Lynn Miranda was like I'm
gonna do it again I'm going to Puerto
Rico you want to come see Hamilton with
me in the lead again you got to come to
Puerto Rico and I'm like I can't make
that work
all these logistical [ __ ] whatever I
don't have the time he's like I'm going
like wait what I'm watching Instagram
sir he's just touring [ __ ] Puerto
Rico just hanging out like drinking mai
tais reset no man you make a Puerto Rico
but whatever and then Hamilton in Puerto
Rico and I've hated him ever since
absolutely so what can we do for you for
right my question is about wrap gifts
can you tell us a
something cool that you got as a wrap
gift and can you tell us about something
cool that you would like to receive as
wrap gifts like a cool idea for one wrap
gifts for those uninitiated are
traditionally at the end of the season
of television or at the wrap of a
production of a movie the the
muckety-mucks or the studio self will
give the people who worked on it some
kind of president to commemorate it
sometimes it's kind of logo on it
sometimes it's got it hey you did this
thing season one also sometimes it's
just like [ __ ] muffins which I'm not
knocking muffin it's like they're
amazing the best wrap gift I got was on
Treadstone I got a mug that you can only
get in the Pentagon that my boss had
gone on a tour of the Pentagon to like
liaised with the people who were like
we're gonna be making fun of and the CIA
whatever and he got to shop at the gift
shop and brought all of us back like
official inside the Pentagon CIA mugs
which is pretty [ __ ] rad the wrap
gift I'd like to get I am pretty sure
that after the first season of friends
those [ __ ] got Porsches so I'd
like a Porsche
please Warner Brothers like I mean I'm
not like a full-size one two not like
some [ __ ] like Barbie rental car
Porsche or some like a remote control I
want a real [ __ ] giant size actual
Porsche I it's a small ask I know but I
feel like I do good work my favorite
gift from a production was actually a
play that I did and I got that I pulled
this quote up why are you talking cuz
that because it was it was I it cost
nothing it was just it was just a
picture frame and in it was a quote from
Shakespeare and love and it just says
boobies
allow me to explain the theater business
the natural condition is one of
insurmountable obstacles on the road to
imminent disaster so what do we do
nothing
strangely enough it all turns out well
how I don't know it's a mystery
that's [ __ ] art man before you go
into production you get that because
you're like how the [ __ ] are we gonna do
this how is all of this going to come
together the truth is there are hundreds
of people from in theater or film and TV
and everyone's got to do their job well
for this thing even for a bad movie to
get may is a miracle so the fact that
anything with all of these people caring
so much because we've grown up with this
thing and we all from from the prop
person to the to the guys who are
cleaning up all of the stuff on the
street they are invested that there's a
there's a guy named Ramon Ramon who who
works on the on The Walking Dead he's
the guy that I that cleans up the
underbrush and and and pulls [ __ ] out of
out of like like muddy dirty cracks he's
been working on this show forever and
you look in his eyes and I was like man
you know it I know we're killing you man
we've been out here for a like-for-like
you know cuz we don't we go 14 18 hours
that's how we go most put most
productions
you know they top out at 12 we [ __ ]
go we [ __ ] go and and and Ramon looks
at me and he was like we make magic in
eight days man let's do this and and
that's what it takes that kind of love
that kind of dedication that is what
what it takes and the truth is is that
it takes all of those people doing this
thing because it's in surmountable
obstacles to try and tell this story and
tell it well in a short period of time
and I and how does it [ __ ] get done
no one knows it's a mystery it's a
mystery the love that's how it happens
that's the way it works so
that little frame that's that's the
thing that I've loved that's pretty
badass
yeah I'm the one that you would want to
get do you also want to Porsche I
wouldn't mind a Porsche I mean if they
handing them out if they handed off
Porsches here's the thing that that I
bet that that I got pissed about because
because when I came on on the show of
The Walking Dead it was it was a it was
an incredible experience you know
phenomenon that was happening and and
they were like they were like man this
is this is crazy
look at what we got for Christmas last
year and he came to me this black card
and it was from Barney's and he died and
it was Lennie James Lennie James the
great lineage Ames who who plays Morgan
on the show and he he was like how much
do you think is on that how much money
as you think is on that card and I was
like I don't know Lenny he was like I
don't know either
I've been using it for for you literally
he was it was like I can't remember the
exact number but it was something and he
was he was like I just shop it Barney's
you know but whatever yeah my daughter
was that let's go let's buy something I
bought all right fine
and so we buy a few things you know and
we're like just wondering how much is on
that card and and they and the guy puts
the thing in and looks at it and he was
like he looks at the screen and he looks
at the card and he looks at Lenny looks
at the screen looks at the car and he
was like could you excuse me for a
minute and he walks away with the card
there were tens of thousands of dollars
on that card hands or thousands of
dollars on that card the next year I got
a lovely coffeepot
[Laughter]
8 million viewers 8 million viewers went
away you know I I get it I get you know
what I mean by lovely comfortable I mean
literally you can make tens of thousands
of a cup of coffee in that coffee
absolutely absolutely and one day I will
I will wear that [ __ ] coffee pot out
so there we go
so that's what you would like I do
believe that we have answered the
question I do believe we're the best of
our ability did we make you happy rhyme
yes thank you
outstanding here you go sir uh well [ __ ]
does anybody else have a question I'm
jealous of Hamilton right now oh my god
I mean like if I could have gotten
myself on I like a freighter plane do
ship that I'm a man now what's happening
and I will you know what
I literally won't go to see it at
Pantages because because it Penta is so
big and you and I want that tiny little
New York theater you know to be able to
watch it again I uh I was like I mean
you can you feel like you can just grab
the stage you can feel them screaming at
you I did hear about the movie I just
saw the trailer for the heights you know
in the heights so and I'm excited about
that you know it's it's always
interesting when you're taking a
theatrical experience and and putting it
on film you know I I just crossed my
fingers and and and hope for you know
magic
but I mean I I was I was a sucker for in
the heights like I saw it at CSUN one
with college students Wow it tore it up
because you know if the underlying
material is good you don't matter you
don't matter but then I saw the trailer
for that movie and I started to tear up
in my car cuz it just looks so full of
life yeah yeah yeah but I I cannot
believe like I and I missed Hamilton on
stage two chances to go see with the
original cast in New York missed them
both first time like I just didn't quite
get it
I'm like I get whatever maybe but it's
super expensive why will really love
this crazy and then I listen to
soundtrack I'm like we should spend as
much money as we have and go see it but
missed it but the fact that they shot
performances on the Richard Rogers stage
with the original cast and and the fact
that that version of it will exist in a
way that's different from the theatrical
experience but with that cast sure in
that place I am I can't [ __ ] wait I
can't but I'm dying to go I've been I've
been trying to figure out a way to get
back to see that again I've only seen it
once on I in in New York and I'm dying
to see it see you see it again it's one
of those things that it's literally you
can't keep clapping it's like this [ __ ]
hasn't has a rhythm in our life that is
that is of its own and and you just need
to get swept up in the end of that into
that wave in that rhythm and it doesn't
stop until it's over and it is awesome
it is just amazing and I got so lucky
dude I don't use this this King zekiel
thing very often yeah but I tried I
tried really hard to get tickets for
Hamilton and I asked everyone and I
could not get tickets for Hamilton I I
mean I was begging but I was like my
manager my agent other people's agents
people aren't on the street anything and
finally it took literally family my
brother's wife's brother's wife's sister
work for like you know some agency who
had some and and she was like I think I
can get you like house seats for for
Hamilton and I didn't know what she
meant by that and I was like I was like
I'm sure we're way up in the rafters or
whatever and and and I'm sick and and
I'm I'm sitting there
oh no no no first I go to see come from
away which is the night the night before
which is a wonderful play about when
when I know
and when people got rerouted to to this
town in Nova Scotia and and the the
relationships that were had there during
that time it was amazing beautiful play
and and and I knew someone who was in
the in the show and I went to went to
see them after the show and he was like
what are you doing tomorrow he's I was
like I'm gonna go see Hamilton he was
like oh oh well I'll let them know that
you're coming and I was like just just
tell them who you are after the show so
you can go backstage and meet everybody
and I was like tell him tell him who I
am Who I am I know who do I tell I don't
know and so I and so I'm sitting there
watching this show I'm you know my
eyebrows are blown off by just amazing
and afterwards I'm like well they he
said I could I could go backstage and
and so I walk I walk back to you know
where people were waiting for the people
to come out and sign autographs and I go
to the big security guard guy and I said
hello I'm car Payton um they said if I
gave you my name that I could go
backstage and he was like sorry Peyton
and I looked at him and I was like I'm
kinga's eek you know from the walking
dead and he was like everybody's here
the chance I have I've never been so
happy in my life
I mean like the you know the the the
whole the what do you call it the tide
the Red Sea parted there you go the Red
Sea parted I walk in there George
Washington is waiting for me you know it
you know it shows me around the stage
and and he was just like you know I the
coach you know it was it was it was
crazy and he was like are you gonna sign
the back of the you know the because
they they have when people come to see
the show you know you sign and say
wonderful show this is amazing and and I
was like you want me to sign the the
wall of the theater and they said Barack
Obama yeah
exactly at either site he was like
you're king of zekiel right and I was
like oh yeah that's right yeah Oh King
Ezequiel give me a pen and and it's and
next to Robert Downey jr. who says who
wrote that's right I'm Robert Downey jr.
I wrote my name on the on the Hamilton
wall it's a I will never forget that
experience for as long as I live
yeah yeah I'm gonna see the movie no
we're gonna go see Hamilton on Broadway
one of these days I'm with the King
exactly what is that velvet we will
exactly we don't wear velvet damn right
ladies and gentlemen have you had a good
time tonight honest-to-goodness none of
this happens unless I get somebody like
Khary Payton to come and stand next to
me dude thank you so much my man rolling
out I had a ball and this this is the
closing of this particular chapter on
black man beyond because like I said
Kevin is coming back in two weeks on the
March third we are we were kicking
kicking the fat man atomic batteries
back up to power the turbines to speed
and we're gonna get back into it so
until we meet again
in this particular place in this
particular way thank you from the bottom
of our heart for showing out and showing
some love and that's it for a black man
beyond tonight all right
my name is water lunch Khary Payton we
will see you same that time same fat
channel SModcast outcome or YouTube
become
youtube.com slash Kevin Smith good night
everybody thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you